foreign
customers are waiting for trucks and
SUVs just like these and many have sat
on that wait list for more than a year
currently we're in body shop this is our
one body shop that we're looking at
right now the electric vehicle company
is now burning through cash rushing to
fill those orders it's a startup trying
to prove it can build vehicles at scale
without having ramped up before it
definitely pressure that's felt that
felt on the floor it's felt by the
entire team so what is the company doing
to build faster and can it become what
investors want it to be the Tesla of
trucks before its competition I toured
rivian's plant and visited Ford's EV
facility to find out
rivian's Factory in Normal Illinois was
previously home to Mitsubishi which
built cars here until 2015. remnants of
that facility like a large part stamping
machine remain
but much of the plant in the process for
making rivian's three vehicles the r1t
r1s and Amazon branded commercial van
are new
as is Tim Fallon who was brought into
rivien in February after 16 years at
Nissan what's job one right now job one
right now is is
um I'll say I don't want to say
finishing the ramp outside continuing
the ramp and getting to stability may be
defined for us what stability means in
us in a factory stability to me is I
want I want people I want all of my team
members technicians to come in and see
the exact same thing they saw yesterday
the parts in the same place the right
number of Parts everything running
appropriately and really being able to
get into that Rhythm and really do the
dance of building vehicles that starts
with stamping from there robots piece
together the parts to form the body This
is highly automated all of the welding
is automated the trucks eventually end
here the general assembly line where
items including seats are locked into
place
getting this entire process to run
smoothly has been a challenge for
ribbian
earlier this year manufacturing issues
sometimes left workers idle for hours
looking back I mean we'd hear about
issues with parts you know sequencing
essentially like not being able to get
the right parts to the right place on
the line at the right time I'm wondering
how you handle that if it's fixed where
you're at in that process there's no
doubt there were there were significant
issues in the past and there are still
some issues that we're working through
but they've gotten significantly better
and you know as we continue to audit our
processes and we continue to refine
those processes and get better we
definitely see fewer and fewer
interruptions to our production because
of it a snarled supply chain and
inflationary pressures have made this
ramp even more challenging Fallon says
rivian in March cut its production
guidance to 25 000 vehicles for the year
last quarter It produced seven thousand
which means it must now build more than
10 000 Vehicles this quarter to hit its
Target
rivien says it's on track to hit its
goal but this Factory has the capacity
to produce six times that 150 000
Vehicles a year
to get there rivian says it's bringing
in more equipment and has recently added
a second shift throughout the facility
can you boil it down to what it is that
would keep you from instead of doing 25
000 this year doing doing 50 000. it's
the working with our supply chain and
then also the ability to get the second
shift on and really get everything
ramped up to that second shift so that
increasing productivity that we'll see
throughout the rest of this year and
into next year will allow us to
consistently be able to get the vehicles
out to our customers at a higher rate
than we have been and then we're looking
at that what is the capacity that we
need to be at to continue to fulfill
that demand that hopefully will continue
to be ever increasing demand for our
vehicles
after the factory tour we borrowed an
r1t to travel back to Detroit a couple
stops to charge made it a nine hour trip
giving me plenty of time to reflect on
what I saw my impression from being
there is the place is super busy but
also you know I don't think the lines
moving at a rate that you'd see in a
traditional Auto Plant you can tell it's
a it's a young Factory that's still
going through some Growing Pains but I
think they feel pretty confident in the
fact that they can scale up from here
rivian CEO RJ scaringe has said he
eventually aims to sell 10 million
Vehicles a year around the world similar
to Toyota today
getting there will mean getting that
plant and future facilities to full
capacity
it's a very different challenge to build
a couple a week versus to build a
hundred it's a very different challenge
to build 100 a week versus 100 a day and
so getting past the first stage doesn't
necessarily prepare you for the second
stage of more higher volume production
ribbian is spending heavily to try to
get there reporting a total net loss to
5 billion dollars in the first three
quarters of this year
if you're an investor in Rivier and you
want to see market share you want to see
a return on investment and so getting a
foothold in the market and establishing
yourself as the leader in EV trucks has
to be the goal for them
rivian was the first EV truck to Market
but it's no longer buyers only option
Ford the leader in gas power pickups is
now selling ITV the F-150 Lightning from
the moment we opened up lightning for
reservations we saw a huge in Rush of
customers we got over 200 000
reservations before we close the
reservation book Ford started delivering
trucks to reservation holders in May and
has so far sold around 13 000 Lightnings
including 2000 in November the company's
Target 150
000 truck annual run rate by the end of
next year or about 12 500 a month
Palmer says that's multiple times the
amount Ford originally planned what
specific actions are you taking to get
to that number the first one is we had
to expand the building size then we have
to reconfigure the lines to run at a
much much higher speed and we of course
had to get the materials for everything
some of Ford's efforts like adding new
equipment hundreds of workers and
pushing speed mirror the moves rivian is
making to boost output but Ford isn't a
startup
it's ramp to production many times
before and next door to its EV facility
is a plant cranking out gas engine
F-150s a new truck rolls off the line
here every 53 seconds my asset has
really been advantageous that we have a
very high speed production plan next
door that builds many of the components
for F-150 especially the aluminum body
we would probably never have been able
to increase So Many Factors speed if we
didn't have the plant next door to rely
on but those shared resources aren't
enough to make an entire electric truck
and Ford has grappled with its own
supply chain constraints you may be
aware of the chip shortage that the
whole industry has been facing that's a
real challenge for us and although we do
prioritize the electric vehicle that's
still a challenge for us when we're
trying to ramp up to such a fast rate
deciding how to allocate chips not to
mention cash between EVs and internal
combustion engine Vehicles is unique to
the traditional automakers the challenge
is more than just the development of the
vehicles and the getting parts to it
it's making this bet on will you be
successful in these if you're
traditional you're taking resources away
from things that are making good money
now to go towards this if you're a
startup you've got very limited
resources and you're putting big bets on
this and to not take those bets almost
guarantees that you lose right now Tesla
is the model for a U.S company
manufacturing EVS at scale It produced
nearly 366 000 vehicles in the third
quarter alone Tesla's cars have
accounted for roughly 68 percent of EVS
sold so far this year in the U.S the
nice thing is the Tesla can't make
enough Vehicles either and so you have
opportunities there you're not going
into a zero-sum game the pie is growing
yeah and Tesla doesn't yet have a truck
like the r1t giving rivien a chance to
establish itself as the go-to name in
the category and to keep investor in
consumer dollars coming in we've talked
to a number of consumers who have their
name on
four different lists they're just trying
to get an electric truck and so it
really is at least in these early days
sort of a race to Market
rivian and Ford's ability to speed up
production and pull ahead of the
competition will impact which vehicles
customers drive or don't drive in the
future
[Music]